When you think "cringe," "The Office" or "Curb
Your Enthusiasm" likely spring to mind, not "Star
Wars." But a moment in "Andor 'has viewers'
secondhand embarrassment alarms going wild.
Spoilers for the first three
episodes of "Andor" ahead.
"Andor" is a completely different beast from
the other "Star Wars" shows to come to Disney+,
Unlike the other series thus far, "Andor"
aims for a grittier, more street-level, and
more solemn look at the "Star Wars" universe,
much in the same way as the movie "Rogue One."
This isn't exactly surprising, given that
"Andor" serves as a prequel to that film,
focusing on the title character Cassian
Andor. As any true "Star Wars" fan knows,
Cassian ends up dying at the end of
"Rogue One," along with all the other
main characters after they've successfully
stolen the plans for the Death Star.
Given the darker tone of the film that inspired
it, and the return of "Rogue One" co-writer Tony
Gilroy as the developer of "Andor," it's really no
wonder that the new series leans into a narrative
heaviness that hasn't been quite as
prevalent in previous Disney+ series.
However, despite that seriousness,
the show also might feature one of
the most cringe-inducing scenes in the entire
"Star Wars" universe in its second episode.
Of course, it's not like "cringe" is new to
"Star Wars" – but this one is on purpose,
meant to make everyone in the audience
feel some secondhand embarrassment.
It's a revealing moment for one of the
main players in this particular saga,
but that doesn't make it any easier to watch.
Deputy Inspector Syril Karn is dead
set on finding Cassian Andor and
bringing him to justice for killing two
guards on the planet Morlana One. Eventually,
he gathers a squad of Prelox-Morlana corporate
authority officers to track down Andor. He's
encouraged to give a speech to the troops to rally
them, but his attempt doesn't exactly go well.
"There's no room for doubt
on the path to… success."
There are a few reasons why the writers likely
decided to go in this direction with Syril and
include such a painfully embarrassing scene.
In the next episode, Cassian and Luthen Rael
manage to outmaneuver Syril and
his soldiers in a show of battle
superiority. So perhaps it's meant
to illustrate his lack of experience.
There is, perhaps, an even deeper meaning behind
the scene, that ties in with Syril's ambitions and
how they're at odds with his actual
abilities. In an interview with Total Film,
Kyle Soller, who plays Syril, revealed
quite a bit about his character. He said,
"He has an extreme sense of need to
impress, and fill a hole in himself.
And so that really is about ascending
to the top of whatever field he's in.
The field he's chosen is one of restriction
and complete control, and one of domination."
Exactly what that metaphorical hole that he's
trying to fill really is will likely become more
clear as "Andor" progresses, but with the added
context of Soller's interview and what fans have
seen of him throughout the first three episodes,
his disastrous speech reveals quite a bit.
Obviously, he wants to impress his
soldiers, but lacks the experience,
proper words, or charm, or
battle prowess to do so.
"Best of luck to us all!"
This also makes him a nice foil for Cassian,
who is more personable and relatable in
his interactions with the other characters.
So while Syril's speech may be a hard scene
to watch, and arguably a top cringe moment
in all of "Star Wars," it's also pivotal
in showing viewers who Syril really is.